so chapter 48 in chapter 49 is if I had
written this book I would have actually
switched the order because chapter 48
talks a lot about developments after
mannequin 2 or right around the time of
Vatican 2 all the way up to the present
and then chapter 49 talks a bit more
about stuff before Vatican feel an
American Catholic culture leading up to
it because it's focused on Catholic
intellectual life and education so we're
gonna do a little bit of backtracking
after we go through all of this stuff
but first a little bit of review
so Catholics have always been a minority
religion in the United States we're down
at that at the sort of point in time
where everybody's religion is a minority
religion there is no one single dominant
religion in the way that's a evangelical
Protestantism at one time it was the
dominant religion in the United States
Catholics have actually become sort of a
bigger and bigger growing concern in
part through immigration in part through
high birth rates which is not so much of
an issue now in part through managing to
hold on to the demographic portion of
the population that they had so we've
got some basic themes up here that
characterize the Catholic experience in
the 19th century of early 20th century
we talked about ethnicity and
immigration any member who's you know
who is associated with the Catholic
Church the Irish Italians the Germans
the Polish we went through all these
different ethnicities and we saw that
they didn't all have the same experience
and we'll talk just a minute about
german-speaking Catholics in particular
Americanization was a huge issue
how much do you adapt yourself to
American Morris to American ways of
looking at things particularly here's
the third thing particularly when
of the sort of American character
contains this threat of anti-catholicism
you know it was particularly virulent in
the mid to late 19th century when we saw
for example the rise of the Ku Klux Klan
as an organization not only devoted to
you know making the lives of African
Americans pretty hellish but also doing
so for Jews and for Catholics whenever
they could find them the know-nothing
party up in the Northeast was involved
in what we would nowadays call terrorist
action you know burning down the convent
accounts as terrorism so there were a
lot of other elements of sort of
typically American culture that were
more geared in subtle ways against
Catholics and to try to get them to
assimilate to try to get them to leave
that stuff behind because it was felt to
be a foreign religion it was felt to be
something that could potentially be
subversive and so there's a lot of
different threads mixing together your
book talks about World War one as being
in some ways a turning moment at least
for German Catholics
well that's wait wait before our time
you know we don't know anybody who was
alive during those generations were
pretty much dying off it's it's
important to remember that until fairly
recently a lot of people who were not
who had at Nyssa T's that were not
originally english-speaking
held on to that if they managed to you
have a community in which you could say
just speak German speak German at home
speak German in school go to you know
see German films at the theater on the
block they would do that I may have
mentioned the example of this woman who
was only you know 30 years older than me
who grew up in Little Italy in Chicago
before it was essentially destroyed by
the interesting
coming in yeah until she was 18 she
didn't realize that the entire world
wasn't Italian because that you could be
that sort of sealed law so World War one
Germany was the main was seen as our
main enemy yeah another thing you may
not realize about World War one there
was actually a German spy ring here in
the United States and they you know they
engaged in again what we would call
terrorist activities nowadays that set
off a wave of anti German hysteria and a
lot of schools where you know classes
were actually taught in German we're
forced to start teaching them in English
because it was thought that look we got
these these foreigners among us can't
figure out what they're saying you know
better get get them to adapt to
Americanize and then maybe they'll knock
off this being a fifth column for the
enemy so there there was a you know sort
of a a swing against this this and the
war itself like they say slow Catholic
immigration considerably there are
already a lot of Catholics here who
emigrated before that and they promoted
the process of Americanization as new
generations were brought up speaking
English as their first language and then
as the Catholic school system the
parochial school system expanded they
made English the language that they were
going to use so it became another way to
to assimilate people so your book talks
about standardization and then they talk
about building Catholic culture
particularly these builder bishops when
you have an expanding population
particularly if you think about at this
point where each generation is bigger
than the generation before it and you
don't have a lot of material resources
your attention tends to be focused on
things like how are we however first of
all how are we going to feed all these
people they have tended not to be such a
big problem in America after you see
there
what are the sort of issues that that
starts to arise when you got a whole
bunch of kids on your hands
yeah no why why is education what so
forth so that sort of you know they can
they add a so that that's important we
be walking these days pitch education in
terms of economics and we often pitch it
in terms of we will keep people from
being dependent we won't have to have
them up give them a dole have them on
welfare if they can actually go to
college get a good job etc etc here so
we're actually talking about like
elementary school middle school high
school there was an economic imperative
to going deeper than that though what
happens to let's say we just said you
know here's an interesting thought
experiment schools are kind of
oppressive
I mean think back to your elementary
school days remember all those tests the
intake and studying and having to sit at
desks and listen and pay attention I
mean what make them better if we just
like let you learn at your own pace what
you wanted to learn you have got so much
freer come and be a much better adjusted
person to ensure if we hadn't imposed
school on you how many even think that
good it would be a better person at this
time if you didn't have wings clipped by
being put through 13 years of K through
12 education probably most of you even
went to preschool to you know so they
got you early maybe you'd be you know
this super dynamic creative genius
that's the way some people actually see
is that yeah he has a friend there goes
something like like a new school or
whatever and I call it where you
basically like set your own curricula
yeah yeah he told me that he's like the
smartest kid he's ever been now
do those sort of things work for
everybody
just imagine some of the kids he went to
school with some of the kids who didn't
have done necessarily going to college
or going to have in college imagine that
in a situation like that would that turn
out well the creative things just come
out and everything would be great I feel
like it would work for life only college
students but like nothing under that
because yeah that what kind of devoted
to yeah I mean if you tell the average
kid you can do whatever you like is what
they like actually studying academic
subjects recess all the time and then
launch of it you know a lot of us like
gym class I know I did or art music
music wouldn't be studying composer just
be doing puttering around with the
instruments what would be wrong with
that really I mean everybody would just
be fine with they out of the economy or
go crap of course cuz they would know
anything but would there be any other
bad effects yeah yeah because the real
world is in many respects one that
doesn't care how you feel or you know
whether you have a reason for your bad
behavior or not or then we could go down
the whole list school plays an important
socializing function this is often white
white people you know raise problems
with homeschooling which actually turns
out to be for the most part quite a good
almost cool kids
tend to do better than most public
school kids depending on where and where
they're going to public school but
school plays a socializing function
teaches us how to get by with each other
as human beings it's also pretty
miserable in many respects as well but
you know can't have a good yeah so
Catholic education was really central to
all of this you have to be able to teach
people basic things and even if even if
kids do go to school oftentimes they
still don't learn the things that we'd
want them to learn they don't require
the sort of literacies think about
history you know that was a central
subject in in schools and they've been a
lot of battles back and forth about how
we should tell the story of history I
find that the last several generations
including mine have a very very hazy
grasp even on American history let alone
world history that puts you had an
incredible disadvantage with respect to
people who actually know history you're
lacking if you don't know history at
least the basic you know anchor points
and you by the way you can't get that
from the History Channel you got
actually read books do it if you don't
have that you're at a disadvantage in
all sorts of other fields compared to
people who actually know it they're at
an advantage and that's unfortunate but
that's a fact of life that's why we
teach history that's why we teach
mathematics that's why we teach writing
that's why you know your teachers were a
pain in the rear with you and gave you
you know red marks because we use commas
your honor because they watch it
actually some of those correctly because
that actually matters so Catholic
schools were assimilating all these kids
and they were always more and more and
more of them and when that's the case
you're paying attention primarily to how
are we going to deal with all of these
people not too big you know
philosophical questions like you know
how should we understand the nature
things like that you're more like how
are we going to raise enough money to
buy the textbooks to you know educate
this this bunch of kids where are we
going to get the space to put them where
are we going to build the new school
that's what all this you know
standardization building Catholic
culture that's where some of that comes
from these demographic pressures through
book talks about builder bishops these
were these are people who presided over
their seas with unchallenged authority
presided over ambitious building proud
programs in which you can do churches
schools hospitals when you have a
growing population you can do that sort
of thing
services nationally recognized
spokespersons on the Catholic position
and the reason they could do that was
because of this sort of standardization
of the Catholic position
so after Vatican to the capacity to do
that kind of arose your book talks about
the the public stance of the
institutional Catholic Church being
relatively uniform they you know they
tended to vote Democrat there's a whole
long history there why that was a case
some of it had to do the Machine
politics some of it had to do with the
Republicans being tied in what sort of
you know something anti-catholicism now
on political issues that primarily
involved economics Catholic sentiment
was was less conservative than you and
II would guess in part because of this
encyclical this encyclical latter by by
Pope Leo the thirteen which is called
railroad Navarre literally means on new
things the notion of social justice that
you'll hear about at least within
Catholic circles comes from that letter
from that encyclical letter and this
gave rise to what was called social
Catholicism this view that society ought
to be
you know change in ways to make
more equitable more just to take care of
the vulnerable the disadvantaged and to
do so in a way that would be very
different than say the Marxist
alternative because there are other
people out there saying that sort of
thing to your book also talks about you
know the whole range of Catholic
ideological positions ranging from
father Coughlin in he had his radio show
there I wanted to say dear mark Royal
Oak Michigan and he was sort of a
proto-fascist type you know a lot of
people in between the two world wars
were attracted to this sort of thing on
the other end a of Dorothy Day and the
Catholic Worker movement Dorothy Day was
originally a communist and she had this
French anarchist friend Peter Monahan
and they found a whole movement oriented
around serving the poor those are those
are still around today these houses of
hospitality you book talks about
Catholic support for world war ii so
once we get up to world war ii that
played the role of helping to
Americanize many catholics world war ii
is this formative experience that we we
we have a hard time relating to because
we don't actually have something like
that in our lifetime 91 it doesn't
really count when it comes to that
because people came together and then
you know when we all went back to our
ideological divides about six months
afterwards world war ii like it says
helped to promote the integration of
many ethnic catholics into the
mainstream of American life how because
when you're in a military unit it's sort
of like you know the same thing that
happens in college in the dorms perhaps
or on teams whether you like people of a
particular group or not or know anything
about them you're stuck with them you
have to sit down next to them eat your
dinner probably share laundry and try to
deal with the fact that you got those
other
they're shooting at you and you're
supposed to admit that that tends to
help us overlook they'll sort of
experiences help us to overlook the
differences between us in a racial
gender national origin ideological when
we're faced with those sort of
situations that tends to help us get
past those sort of things another thing
that was really important was the GI
Bill why why was that important yeah
there is this incredible proliferation
of colleges after World War two
in part because they realized that one
day once all these guys come back we had
millions of people in the armed services
once these people come back we better
find something for them to do and
education was seen as sort of an avenue
towards success
so colleges sprang up overnight
there weren't enough college spots to
actually satisfy all of the guys who
have the GI Bill a lot of colleges
particularly state colleges I'm learning
from GI Bill other things to culinary
that's Culinary Institute of America
right down the road that was a GI bill
essentially founded operation they
didn't start there I used to get Jesuit
monastery they started up Gail's grounds
if I remember right and then they moved
down here once they bought that land for
the Jesuits but it was to provide
servicemen who come back from World War
two with a education now what that did
again is that helped integrate Catholics
into American public life so your book
then sort of fast-forwards us up to the
1960s besides sex drugs rock and all
what else the associate
and sixties yeah yeah that was a hugely
divisive issue we were embroiled in this
Vietnam conflict and our involvement
started in you know in some ways in
1950s when I started taking things over
from the French by the 1960s were
heavily involved and the draft was still
going on
felt disproportionately poor and the
lower middle class and there was there
seemed to be no end in sight for
Catholics were kind of divided about
this some Catholics were heavily
involved in the anti-war movement
because Christianity is supposed to be
about peace on the other hand who are we
fighting in Vietnam yeah exactly yeah
cuz you can't be a common as well being
godless you can't actually but not a
traditional Marxist one and so a lot of
Catholics were lined up behind anty anty
communists so there was a lot of
division on that issue around this time
your book talks about the two jobs and
they don't mean people who frequent you
know ladies of the night or anything
like that
to John's that are rising to to to
prominence at the head of their
organizations what does John Kennedy
first Catholic president not the first
Catholic to run for president but the
first one who actually makes it and he
was not you know who's not a
particularly good guy when we actually
look at the historical record nor
particularly competent and interrelation
other presidents but the fact that he's
assassinated allows him to be turned
into this almost saintly figure for at
least a generation to represent
something you know this brief moment of
shining hope they call it Camelot I'm
actually kind of happy that nobody talks
about that anymore because because my
generation I you know he died a long
time before
born I had to hear these these you know
people When I was your age I hear people
my age constantly going on and on and on
about if Kennedy hadn't been
assassinated and blah blah blah blah
sick of it after a while
some people start doing historical
research and finding out that you know
he was not that super great guy people
thought but there's a more important job
so Kennedy kind of shows that Catholics
can make it they can rise to the highest
office in the land
he was historic in the way that Barack
Obama's presidency is historic for
african-americans and we have a woman
president it will be historic for for
women you know showing that one can
actually make it to the top
Jonathan 23rd was a pope john xxiii
convenes the Second Vatican Council
that's really the key turning point of
this chapter and of American Catholicism
in the 20th century you have a second
vatican council he called upon the
bishops when you have a council all the
bishops come together he called upon the
bishops to sort of reassess where to
pollicis and once in important respects
and he wasn't calling for everything to
change completely but there were a lot
of things where they did make some very
important changes for example prior to
Vatican soon unless you belong to an
Eastern Rite your mass was in Latin and
the priests conducted the mass facing
away from you the entire time
one of the changes that was made through
the switch to the vernacular was
actually having the priests face the
congregation it became sort of a
dialogue between congregation and
priests some people think it went too
far to turn into you know priestess
performer there were a lot of other
things that came in as well changes of
what
Surgical music here's just one example
of this that that's sort of emblematic
full of music you can quit popular to
use in churches and you know for people
who had grown up on organ music and a
certain song blood that you used this is
a huge departure yeah I'm bringing in
guitars oftentimes I've meant in
bringing guys with long hair or kind of
hippie type stuff that didn't sell too
well on some of the congregations but
these are just some of the examples it
also led to questioning authorities
questioning the standardization than it
taken place there's a lot of conflicting
interpretations about just what the
Second Vatican Council means some
Catholics on the left think that the
church never went far enough and that
they should you know keep changing
everything some Catholics on the right
think that Vatican two of here on the
far right Atika to is an illegitimate
set of changes and you know the Pope
abandon Catholicism when the bishops
abandon Catholicism if you're on the
middle right you probably think that
they went too far with them with some of
the implementation of the Second Vatican
Council so turned out to be this
incredibly polarizing thing but it also
set American Catholicism on a new path
indeed world Catholicism because the
idea behind it was what they call the
journa mento bringing things up to date
they also had another fancy where they
used resource and law going back to the
original sources so instead of just
focusing on the Middle Ages and Thomas
Aquinas focus on the actual Gospels on
the Church Fathers these people who are
interpreting things soon after that and
see what they had to say look at the
example of the early church your book
that also talks about politics quite a
bit and some American Catholic figures
it brings up Geraldine Ferraro who
none of you would remember because she
was a has-been by the time that you were
you know growing up but you remember
John Kerry John Kerry was a Catholic
candidate for the presidency and he
didn't win the Catholic vote that was
part of it lost in the election the
seven evangelical George Bush got a
slightly larger percentage of the
Catholic vote and it actually when you
look at the demographics for Catholics
who go to church once a week or more he
actually he hammered that and Kerry lost
that vote altogether
why what happened there shouldn't the
Catholics have voted for the Catholic
the current governor of New York
his dad was was a Catholic figure did
the same sort of thing as Kerry but he
was he was pretty successful might not
have been successful he ran for
president though why to carry lose the
Catholic vote there's nothing you know
inherently about Catholicism that says
you should vote Republican he should
have been there there guy right well he
was out of line with the church on a lot
of teachings that many Catholics
consider to be pretty important this is
a very important political issue
you know abortion it's hard to get away
from that the Democratic Party used to
be the party of Catholics but it has it
swung further leftward on that and had
some other issues and marginalized
Catholics who actually were pro-life
like governor Casey in the 1990s they
they effectively you know they didn't
necessarily lose the Catholic vote and
not the Catholic vote one Republican but
they they cut a lot all of its necessary
moorings with the Democratic Party so
there's a lot of Catholics that account
kind of divided we're also the Catholics
sort of
made it there book talks about the
Supreme Court I don't know if you
realize it Catholics are the biggest
group in the Supreme Court right now
that would have been unthinkable century
ago because of anti-catholicism because
of the view that love your Catholic he
was going to do it over the Pope tells
you vatican ii evidence showed us they
don't mean anything showed us that
Catholics don't always you know do what
they're what they're being told your
book talks about the traditionalist
movement I'm gonna skip over that
probably more interesting is what we
call charismatic this came about after
that I came to as well and remember when
we talked about hostels Pentecostal what
springs to mind
besides snakes anything that comes to
mind what happened at Pentecost
there's tons of fire okay so this is
speaking in tongues manifesting what
they call the gifts of the Spirit and
usually tended with a fairly an
emotional way of worship there were
twenty few Catholics and other
Protestants that got attracted to this
so what they what they talk about this
in terms of is the charismatic but
having accurate literally race yeah so
that's been kind of a marginal thing but
it's been there as a sort of
undercurrent for quite a while there's
some pretty fairly traditional Catholic
institutions where that's a significant
concern like Franciscan University
Steubenville which is usually associated
with conservative Catholicism they're
also a charismatic institution your book
also talks about some major changes in
ethnicity yeah this has to do with a
great
you're not getting a lot of Catholics
immigrated from Germany in the late 20th
century you are getting a lot of
Catholics immigrating from other places
where are they coming from because where
they're coming from changes of the face
of the church in America particularly
sets you know the Germans the Irish was
polish the Italians they more or less
become Americanized they're now a third
fourth fifth generation where does the
new immigration come from it's not
coming from your book does talk about
Hungary okay cuz you know after the
Communists come in and crackdown same
thing also it's for certainly the checks
but for the most part it's like coming
from Europe where's the immigration
coming from yeah okay so who would this
include yeah right you know unless you I
suppose your transplanted German or it's
not know that America you're probably
going to be a Latino in one form or
another that's a Spanish speaker right
so we have Mexicans coming up oftentimes
actually some of us are there some of
the selfies Western states already being
there you know the United States took
larger portions Mexico from Mexico where
else where else is the immigrants
where's the where's the spanish-speaking
integration think about New York New
York City
yeah at Puerto Rico is a massive
influence on the East Coast in general
where else yeah yeah there are some
Cubans in other places but Florida's
where most of them are settling parties
it's so close again I'm driven out by
the communists so then you know there's
other places too I'll say all the door
because of the civil war going on there
we're also it makes sense though there'd
be a lot of Catholic integration from
from Latin and South America given that
those are largely Catholic areas we're
also the world you find a lot of
Catholics Europe South America yeah
right so this is something particularly
recently there's been quite a bit of
African integration it probably will be
as a matter of fact the problems that
are occurring with with priestly
vocations in you know what we call the
developed world where you're not getting
enough young men who want to be priests
going to seminary they're not having
those problems in Africa so you will see
a lot of parishes today where there are
African priests or polish priests
because they're having to get a lot of
vocations in Poland Catholicism in
America is taking on an incredibly
international sort of characters in part
cos it's a World Church Vietnam you know
and and all the other things happening
in Southeast Asia liken in Laos and
Cambodia that drove some immigration
because those areas had a lot of
Catholics who are you know because the
French were there your book also talks
about Haiti and so when it happens in
general as these newcomers are coming in
and the same dynamics of you know
non-english languages are coming up the
same adaptations are having to take
place and then your book also talks
about one other particularly interesting
future Catholic outreach to the African
Americans we don't often associate
Catholicism and African Americans
Catholicism in Africa itself yes because
of the French influence the Portuguese
influence the Spanish influence
mission worked on the English
territories but there there were in fact
areas where African Americans became an
important part of the Catholic Church as
a matter of fact one of the presidents
of the American Catholic Bishops
welcomed Gregory as it was an African
American what is an African American
didn't change so stupid to say things
like that's nice
your book talks about Kathleen Drexel or
Katharine Drexel sorry should be finally
through [ __ ] she founds this order the
sisters of the Blessed Sacrament why to
promote missionary work among African
Americans and there are some some black
religious orders that your book talks
about as well the last thing that your
book really discusses well there's two
two less things you look really
discusses in here one is there's really
no way to get around this the sexual
abuse which people are still feeling
reverberations of today yeah I think
it's probably worth spending a little
bit of time talking about that and and
what occurred in part because it's
become part of American mythology you
can still find comedians you know the
Catholic priest becomes this figure that
you can have a million jokes at the
expense of because of that what went on
with this sexual abuse scandal there
were a lot of different components -
there was abuse that took place and a
lot of the times when when it was
reported why did the bishops get in so
much trouble over this
some of the bishops moved priests around
from parish to parish giving them sort
of slap on the wrist sometimes for
decades you realize that the the scandal
that we're talking
and for the most part occurred back
decades ago even even when it was you
know sort of unfolding it was mostly
about decades ago it was it was how they
handled it and then the question people
why it was this tolerated why was this
allowed to do I was the church itself
corrupt
is there something inherent about you
know Catholicism and it's it's you know
view on order and hierarchy that that
brings us about one of the answers is
that at the time that a lot of this was
going on bishops were being told that
child molesters can be fixed can be
healed and that they had a beauty to
allow this to take place nowadays
psychiatrists and psychologists are much
more pessimistic about the possibility
of doing this and so part of the part of
what's going on and I don't mean to
trivialize this is the bishops were
being held the standards that didn't
exist at the time that they were making
these decisions some of them actually
did some make some really bad decisions
Cardinal law I had to resign as a matter
of fact when Cardinal law went to john
paul ii funeral the other Catholic
Cardinals wouldn't have anything to do
with them
because they the other thing that it
talks about is some of the key what we
might call bullet point talking points
when Catholics get together and argue
about where the church is going there's
quite a few of you that are that are I
would say ethnically Catholic you grew
up in Catholic neighborhoods and
Catholic families some of you went to
Catholic school what are the sorts of
things that Catholics argue with each
other about having to do with with the
nature
it's the sort of things that if you want
to get people arguing just throw these
things on the table yeah boring churches
yeah
let the liturgical question right how
should how should the liturgy be yeah
because like in some ways it's very like
this yeah that's a I'm laughing in part
because it's such a great way of putting
it it's very very down-to-earth and
people do argue about how should the
liturgy go if we have this going on over
here does that compromise the tradition
you know and it's very difficult to
satisfy everybody what else
so that's a perennial issue what else
follow the lines we're getting confirmed
yeah I saw a lot of my peers and I was
at the kicks I don't know we're getting
confirmed because you get presents and
mom and dad expect it but it produces
this sort of conflict of identity
there's other issues too I mean that
should there ever be women priests
that's a debated issue you know what
about birth control contraception you
know sex before marriage this is one of
those things where Catholics are kind of
all over the map aren't they the church
should liberalize and now the trip
shouldn't liberalize what one of these
things on the table as a talking point
you know with a bunch of Catholics and
you'll get them arguing in part because
there's a lot of ferment going on within
the church about these things as well